قالت القياده الوسطى الامريكيه ان قواتها
اسقطت مسيره فوق خليج عدن بدون وقوع
اصابات او اضرار مضيفه ان قواتها دمرت
مركبا مفخخا مسيرا تابعا للحوثين في البحر
الاحمر واوضحت القياده ان المركب المسيره
كان يبحر صوب خطوط الشحن ومثل تهديدا
وشيكا للسفر التجاريه وسفن الحربيه
الامريكيه وذكرت ان الحوثيين اطلقوا
صاروخين بالستيين مضادين للسفن مسته فين
على الارجح السفينه التجاريه كوي وقد سقط
في البحر
الاحمر اعلن المتحدث العسكري باسم جماعه
انصار الله الحوثيين استهداف سفينه تجاريه
بريطانيه في البحر الاحمر كانت متجهه الى
موانئ فلسطين المحتله وذلك بصواريخ بحريه
مناسبه وكان سري في منشور على منصه ياكسن
عمليات الجماعه في البحرين العربي والاحمر
ضد الملاحه الاسرائيليه او السفن المتجهه
الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله مستمره حتى وقف
العدوان ورفع الحصار عن قطاع
غزه